Earlier we mentioned that healthcare in the US was
traditionally charged based on the amount of care that was delivered.
This is usually termed pay for procedures.
HMOs are an example of an alternate model in which there is fixed reimbursement.
So if Kaiser spends less than its premium income it makes a profit.
In fact, like most nonprofits,
Kaiser still needs earnings to invest in its business.
However, this relies on Kaiser employing all the physicians,
owning all the hospitals and more.
Can we create something similar on a much smaller scale using physicians,
hospitals, and other community health resources that are already in place?
In 2006, Dartmouth professor, Elliott S. Fisher,
first used the term accountable care organization to describe such a proposed solution.
The details are complex but the basic idea is to create
a financial model under which existing community providers can organize and deliver
care in a way that improves the quality and lowers the cost of
care by fostering greater accountability
on the part of the providers for their performance.
One of the key provisions of
the Obama administration's Affordable Care Act was the creation of ACOs within Medicare.
This model is also now widely advocated by commercial health insurance companies.